che meraviglia
mi sarebbe piaciuto essere qui con la
mia stratocaster però sono troppo merda
per questo quindi faccio videogiochi
crea mondi virtuali e vi parlerò di
questo mondi virtuali come questo che
vedete dietro di me questa è una foto
stereoscopica che ha più di un secolo
una foto stereoscopica è una foto 3d che
ha due immagini
molti di voi già lo sapranno ma fate
provate a fare questo esperimento come
mettere il pollice davanti a voi così e
guardate me guardatemi fisso
ora chiudete un occhio e l'altro occhio
vedete che il pollice rispetto a mesi
sposta l'effetto della profondità non fa
parte di ciò che vediamo con gli occhi è
costruito dal nostro cervello
confrontando due immagini e per
confrontare due immagini ci vogliono due
occhi ovviamente oppure si devono avere
due foto molto simili ma diverse e
vederle mandando un immagine ad ogni
occhio come si faceva con questo oggetto
inventato volontariamente non brevettato
un secolo e mezzo fa la holmes che
permetteva di visualizzare foto in 3d
era l'inizio del turismo virtuale che
poi è continuato se vi ricordate negli
anni 50 60 c'erano questi viso rini di
plastica come questo il master dove si
giravano le foto a colori terra in 3d e
questo concetto piatto e un certo punto
quando è cominciato il digitale a una
serie di aziende che pensano di
utilizzarlo per l'intrattenimento
tra queste dopo per esempio virtuale ci
si può anche nintendo che costruì questo
adorabile virtual boy
che però non ebbe tanto successo anzi fu
veramente un flop
non tanto per la grafica non proprio
meravigliosa come potete vedere insomma
monocromatica ma perché non era
immersivo cioè non ti dava la sensazione
di stare in un ambiente tridimensionale
non potevi voltarti per risolvere questo
problema moltissimi hanno lavorato per
dare più il senso di questa immersione
nei modi più curiosi e più fantasiosi
tra cui questo fantastico ed home della
tossiva del 2006 che non si capisce
perché non ha avuto successo
però l'idea di avere la proiezione cui
avevi un proiettore in testa e uno
schermo addosso ma l'idea di avere lo
schermo intorno non era male noi
l'abbiamo utilizzata qui vicino ad
ercolano al museo archeologico virtuale
il mav
dove c'è uno schermo di 26 metri in cui
viene visualizzata in 3d la
ricostruzione dell'eruzione del 79
raccontata dal punto di vista del
vesuvio in prima persona però i visori
continuano ad andare di moda ma con il
fattore dell'immensità quindi girandosi
come questo fantastico cruz lift che è
molto bello a un campo di vista molto
ampio è piaciuto anche molto a mark
zuckerberg che ha pensato di comprarsele
trovandosi a comprà tutta l'azienda per
2 miliardi di dollari quindi insomma ha
fatto un acquisto ma volendo mantenere
più bassi anche google è entrata nel nel
mercato della realtà virtuale con questo
oggetto che potete scaricare in forma di
pdf ritagliare e stampare a casa oppure
ordinarlo già fatto in questa casa
vedete ci troviamo di fronte a una cosa
molto simpatica perché ecco il progresso
dal 1861 al 2014 i due oggetti si
somigliano veramente molto salvo per il
fatto che lo smartphone è attivo è
interattivo
allora questa interazione la chiave e
noi abbiamo utilizzato lo stesso
concetto questo è un mio collaboratore
abbiamo aggiunto delle telecamere e lui
si trova in realtà a pompei ma non solo
si trova lì perché ce lo vedete voi ma
lui si vede lì adesso entriamo nella sua
testa e questo è quello che vede lui ma
lo vede in 3d a e l'ambiente in cui si
trova è interattivo lui può muoversi può
camminare può vedere le proprie mani può
agitare la fiaccola che non esiste
allora mi chiedono spesso ma questo è
reale o virtuale come se il virtuale
fosse il reale come se tutto ciò che è
reale fosse aiuta accendono gli usi come
dicevano i pink floyd solo quello che
possiamo toccare come se il il velo di
maya non vizia se la nostra percezione
eppure noi siamo già in una realtà
aumentata
voi avete molti di voi hanno un
telefonino addosso che si sta
geolocalizzando che ha connessioni un
profilo digitale yo è come se vedesse
tutti i felini che vi collega dall'uno
all'altro almeno di alcuni di voi li
vedo
e questo è qualcosa che sta già
succedendo adesso solo che non è
visibile virtuale lo rende visibile ed è
artificiale certo ma l'artificio una
caratteristica dell'uomo l'uomo non si è
conquistato la sua posizione nell
ecosistema terrestre per quel che vale
attraverso il vantaggio evolutivo di
denti aguzzi o una corazza più forte lo
ha fatto con la comunicazione ma
soprattutto con l'intelligenza e la
capacità di modificare l'ambiente di
costruire a volte violentando la natura
altre volte facendo cose meravigliose
come questo teatro tra l'altro il
termine realtà virtuale
è stato coniato proprio per definire le
rappresentazioni teatrali e allora se
pensiamo a questo a quanto all'artificio
faccia parte di noi e al fatto che ci
stiamo spostando a costruire invece che
sempre strade ed edifici oggetti
tridimensionali virtuali in cui
interagire che non sono più un livello
separato o alternativo non scimmiottano
la realtà ma la completano se ci
rendiamo conto di come viviamo sempre di
più in questa realtà aumentata che ci
pervade che si confonde con la realtà
materiale digitale il materiale si
compenetrano e si completano
allora capiamo che se un'esperienza del
genere camminare oggi per le strade di
una pompei viva può generare in me delle
emozioni e quelle emozioni sono vere
allora anche quella realtà virtuale si
chiama realtà proprio perché vera e
grazie alla tecnologia
mai come oggi è stata così irreale
grazie